On January the 1st 2019 Jaya bowls Inara
one of the most controversial
politicians in international news became
the presidents of Brazil
[Music]
Martha Nara came to power with a promise
to change Brazil the fifth largest
country in the world giant that has more
than 200 million people from top to
bottom in an attempts to turn it into a
political and economic power however
both scenarios first 100 days into his
term has headlines like these yeah year
busan RO brazil's apprentice president
unless he stops provoking and learns to
govern his tenure could be short the
Christian Coalition that helped elect
bosun ro has started to crumble bosun
Otto's popularity sinks after a rocky
100 days in Brazil since becoming
president Bolson ro is continued with
his incendiary and controversial
campaign speech he remains very active
in social networks in there's no day in
which he doesn't attack other parties
and other politicians which is strange
considering that he himself has been in
politics for 30 years and has three
children who are also politicians my god
what have I done to deserve this nothing
but trouble
yeah your bull Senado now how can you
use controversy to govern a country how
can you secure power without seeking
pacts or political supports and the most
important resident of all what exactly
can we expect from bolson ro well listen
up
[Applause]
[Music]
October the 28th 2018 was a historic day
for Brazil in the second rounds after a
very heated campaign that caught global
attention and in which the current
presidents was even stabbed
Walden ro finally won majority support
from Brazilian voters specifically he
won fifty five point one three percent
of the vote his victory dethroned the
Workers Party Lula da Silva's party a
party that had completely dominated
Brazilian politics for 16 years
Walden ro is character known this harsh
speech for his support of the military
dictatorship and his controversial
comments in many cases comments of a
homophobic sexist and even racist nature
he promised he ends the extensive
corruption that has been ravaging Brazil
to fight relentlessly against the
violence that has turned Brazil into one
of the most dangerous countries in the
world indeed fifty to sixty five
thousand people are murdered there every
single year and of course to dismantle
the gigantic political framework that is
currently crippling Brazil's society and
economy it was precisely his economic
promises that generated the most
excitement during his campaign causing
many liberals to side with balsan ro
intern balsan re delegated the economic
section to a group of Chicago boys led
by the Minister of Economy Paulo G DES
and it makes sense to overhaul the
economy because Brazil can't keep
running like it has been running it hold
on a moment because although ball
scenario 1 the presidential elections he
doesn't hold a legislative majority his
party only got fifty five of the 513
seats that make up the Chamber of
Deputies and this is important because
if you don't have a majority in the
legislature and you don't seek political
support from other elected parties well
how are you going to get any laws
approved
[Music]
Brazil's Congress and Senate are very
fragmented which is why previous
Brazilian presidents have traditionally
ruled by forming pacts with other groups
this is known as coalition presidential
ism however balsan on route simply
doesn't work that way
and of course this isn't the only
handicap of the new Brazilian President
[Music]
Z to say hard to do
Brazil is chaotic it's by far one of the
most bureaucratic and complicated
countries in the world and it's that way
for everyone ordinary people companies
since even for politicians you want an
example of what bureaucracy means in
Brazil well check this out it's
estimated that a medium-sized company
even a small company spends about 2,000
hours a year declaring their taxes this
may help explain why Brazil scores lower
than even Argentina in the economic
freedom index and is considered to be
one of the seven countries in the world
where taxes and most cumbersome to pay
according to the World Bank's Doing
Business Index check this out
[Music]
and on top of that taxes aren't even low
in fact quite the opposite in short is
all just a bit of a crazy system the
point is that it feels like bolson are
is lack of evidence is taking its toll
[Music]
it may be surprising to hear Molson re
described as inexperienced when he's
been in politics in more than 30 years
and almost all that time he served as a
federal deputy however this time was
served in what Brazilian politics calls
low clergy that is politicians with
minimal power these are characters who
are in politics but who neither have the
ability to influence nor take part in
actual decision-making while the fact is
that since he was appointed president
Bolton ro hasn't had a clear agenda his
first months in office have been sort of
a sequence of meaningless fights
controversial statements sudden changes
of opinion may etcetra etcetra along the
way two ministers have already been
fired and all of this has happened in
just three months
so apart from attacking the press which
happens all the time we don't really
know what it will be up to you from one
day to the next and of course some
important ideas have been discussed such
as commemorating the 1964 coup that led
to the dictatorship it's almost as if he
thinks that Brazil doesn't have any more
pressing matters than opening up these
debates
[Music]
alas not all ball scenario himself who
came to power as a champion in the fight
against corruption has seen its shadow
loom very close to him one of his son
Senator Flavio bolson RA received 48
suspicious deposits worth $30,000 in his
bank account according to reports
obtained and broadcast by journal
Nacional among other scandals there have
been reports of the diversion of public
electoral funds by bowl scenarios social
Liberal Party to fake candidates in the
previous elections these accusations led
to the dismissal of the general
secretary of the presidency Gustavo
Debbie Arno who was none other than the
coordinator of ball scenarios own
campaign not exactly a brilliant start
and this helps to explain how in just
three months the president's approval
rating among Brazilians dropped 16
points and the confidence index has gone
from 62 percent in January to 49 percent
in March look we're talking about the
worst record of a Brazilian president at
the beginning of his term since 1990 but
folks this really is just the start of
the problems my enemy's enemy is my
friend an election campaign is always
different from governing a country for
example in a campaign you could promise
gold and moran's create alliances
between parties and politicians whose
only affinity is their rejection of a
different political opinion that's
exactly what happened in Brazil Multan
RA managed to bring together all the
different groups that were fed up with
the workers party's policies however
there's one problem once you reach power
and you have to govern that's when the
differences really begin to show this is
what seems to be happening in Brazil
right now
you see the support system the lead ball
scenario to the presidency includes just
a bit of everything anti Marxists
evangelists liberals traditionalists the
military conservatives it goes on and on
and of course sometimes the differences
they really do matter in a nutshell we
could say that there are two main
currents within balsan aras governments
pragmatists and ideologists among the
pragmatists who are those groups willing
to negotiate with other political forces
of the military and the Liberals for
example the liberal group led by the
powerful economy minister Pablo guita's
defended much more aggressive reforms
during the campaign than those it
defends now that there empower and
that's because they need support in
order to get those reforms through a
very clear example is pension reform
during the campaign be des defended
reforming the entire system using the
Chilean model as an example in short he
was promoting a capitalization model now
however he's promoting significant
reforms but they are nowhere near as
ambitious a minimum retirement age a
capped pension and eligibility based on
a required number of years in the
workforce the governments will still
save a lot of money but basically the
system structure will remain the same
and of course in order to approve even a
moderate pension system reform they need
three-fifths of the congressmen and
Senators to vote in favor so while it's
time to negotiate the second current
that runs through all scenarios
governments is the ideological one and
this group includes the president's own
children as I mentioned the entire
family is involved in politics
I've never seen anything like it I don't
remember any other government in which
the family has so much power as this one
family is always a problem the president
needs to keep some distance from his
family and friends Fernando Henrique
Cardoso former president of Brazil the
fact is that the ideologists are the
least willing to negotiate or seek
consensus
it's piloted by this man olavo de
Carvalho balsan Aras Steve Bannon he's a
self-taught writer and philosopher who
lives in the United States and is pretty
extreme he's part of what's known as the
old right and well his approaches are a
cocktail loaded with anti-communism anti
globalism anti cultural Marxism
anti-lgbt and a a whole lot of
conservatism this character has even
criticized the pragmatic leaders in both
scenarios government a la ville de
Carvajal qualifies manaro the Vice
President as an idiot and says the
government is running badly yes that's
right there are already clashes between
the groups that make up the governments
and if that's within the government you
can imagine how hard it will be to find
agreements with the rest of the
parliamentary forces in fact in just
three months the government has already
been defeated several times in Congress
but folks we still need to talk about
balsa narrows that handicap
the economy doesn't work we should state
that this isn't Bowl senarios fault as
it seems fundamentally from the disaster
caused by the previous government the
Workers Party which led Brazil into one
of its worst crises in 2016 but even if
it's not their fault ball scenarios
government is going to have to deal with
it and work with an economy that's not
the forming basically the country has a
huge public deficit of between 7 & 8
percent per year
public debt keeps growing and it's
already at around 80 percent which is a
lot for a country like Brazil to make
matters worse there are 13 million
unemployed people and the economy is
really struggling City cuts 2019 Brazil
GDP growth forecast 1.8 percent faced
with this situation Brazil doesn't need
an economy minister they need a doctor
obviously such a big deficit doesn't
give the government much margin for
anything and if you have huge imbalances
and no growth things are only gonna get
harder of course this only one solution
and that's budget cuts and that's
precisely what the government wants to
do with pensions which is by far the
largest expenditure for the Brazilian
governments more than 40% of the
government's budget goes to pensions and
some estimates even suggest that in the
next decade this is going to rise above
60% this is not surprising because
Brazil has one of the most generous
systems in the world the country's
average retirement age is 54 years and
the average pension is equivalent to 70%
of the final salary that means you can
retire at age 54 and for the rest of
your life you're going to get 70% of the
salary you were earning just before you
retired obviously this is not
sustainable Brazil has one of the most
generous systems in the world
if there is no pension reform Brazil
will head towards insolvency and a debt
crisis Chris Garmin managing director of
Eurasia Group a political risk advisory
firm the rolling cuts then ever-popular
and folks at Bolton re-really wants to
change Raziel for good he's going to
have to negotiate and that means a lot
of compromise the question is can he do
it well leave your answer in the
comments below and in this survey anyway
as you could see these are factors that
have overshadowed Bowl scenarios first
months as president if he manages to
build a coalition of political support
to transform the Brazilian economy well
were we glad to tell you about it and if
he doesn't his government may not last
very long at all so I really hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button if you did and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos also
please check out our friends at
reconsider media there the podcasts that
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform that he's
considered joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]